two longtime cbs executives are on
administrative leave this morning while
the company looks into
alleged racist and sexist behavior first
reported by the los
angeles times peter dunn cbs television
station's president and david friend
senior vice president of news for the
stations were suspended pending fulham a
full investigation
by parent company viacom cbs our
national correspondent jerica duncan has
the details
according to allegations laid out in the
los angeles times investigation
peter dunn's management was hostile
racist
and crude according to legal papers
obtained by the l.a times from a former
employee of our philadelphia station kyw
tv
dunn referred to veteran anchor yuki
washington who's black
as jive another former employee echoed
that claim
philadelphia health officials dunn
allegedly disparaged washington
often according to the l.a times and
would say that quote
all he does is dance in a statement on
air last night
kyw sportscaster don bell responded to
the story
our uakey washington is the most
hard-working
authentic caring and skilled journalist
i've ever been around
yuki is our quarterback he's the crown
jewel of philly
but the allegedly harmful rhetoric did
not stop with dunn
according to claims in the times report
his lieutenant
senior vice president david friend also
disparaged colleagues
he was allegedly critical for example
when kyw hired journalist brook thomas
as a morning anchor in 2016.
former news director margaret cronin
described to the la times a phone call
with
friend on thomas's second day on air as
just
venom and profanity he screamed tell her
to shut the expletive
up thomas who was black was let go just
months later
we have spent every weekday morning
together for the last two years
and according to the times report dunn
allegedly objected to extending the
contract
of journalist rahel solomon who's
ethiopian and had replaced thomas
in part because quote i hate her face
in a statement to the times friends said
these comments i
may have made about our employees or
prospective hires
were only based on performance or
qualifications
not about anyone's race or gender
former cbs this morning co-host charlie
rose was terminated over sexual
harassment allegations
in 2017 allegations which he denies
after his firing cbs began an
investigation
into workplace culture allowing
employees to share any stories of
alleged harassment
a subsequent investigation eventually
led to the firing
of then chairman and cbs ceo les moonves
who denies all allegations of misconduct
allegations against peter dunn came up
during investigations into workplace
culture in 2019.
former kyw general manager brian kennedy
says
dunn fired him for cooperating with the
investigation
cbs released a statement to the l.a
times this week
saying they haven't had any complaints
against dunn since
on sunday night cbs entertainment group
chief
george cheeks met with leadership from
the national association of black
journalists
afterward nabj said in a statement that
in order for the company's culture to be
transformed
it must begin with the firing of dunn
and friend
in an internal email monday cheeks
promised to foster and maintain a
positive inclusive and equitable
workplace
the network also committed to an
independent investigation
of the allegations raised in the times
and said it would take appropriate
action in a public statement
announcing dunn and friends suspensions
for cbs this morning
jerika duncan in his public statement
george sheik said cbs is committed to a
diverse
inclusive and respectful workplace where
all voices are heard
claims are investigated and appropriate
action is taken where necessary
we reached out to peter dunn and david
friend for comment
but have not heard back